Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Subhanah tells us guide us the straight
path. This is a verse that we recite
every day in every
of every salah. And asking for this is a
condition
in order for our prayer to be considered
acceptable for our prayer's validity.
What is
what is the straight path? Guide us the
straight path. Notice the curious
wording. Guide us the straight path.
Meaning, guide us to the straight path
and guide us on the straight path and
guide us in the straight path.
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala
he tells us
that there is such a thing as the
straight path of Allah.
He refers to this path elsewhere as
the path of Allah.
What is this path? Our prophet
sallall.aii wasallam
has
told us of this path and he has
described it to us.
There's a narration which was collected
by
immed
on the authority of an
in which the prophet sallall.aii
said
gives us a parable, an analogy of our
path to him.
Our entire life, every waking moment,
from the point that you or I began to
understand right from wrong,
left from right, up from down,
we have been invited to this path to
embrace it, to stay in it.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
has guided us to this path from the
inception
from the moment he created Adam
and breathed life into him because a
human being without guidance
is not just a lifeless being but a
lifeless satellite.
We've been designed to be guided.
And if a person has that part missing,
not only will their dunya suffer, not
only will their a be at stake or lost,
but they will always be incomplete.
And so what is this straight path that
Allah has described to us? Our prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam says in this
narration,
Allah has given us an analogy of our
path to him and the path of guidance as
a straight and broad open path.
He says
Allah gives an analogy of his path as a
straight broad open path clear and no
crookedness in it. And on both sides of
this path, all the way down from the
start to finish are walls.
And in these two walls, on either side
of the path, there are open doors.
And on each of these open doors, there
is a curtain that is hanging down and
covering what's behind that door. So to
understand the analogy, our prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam is
describing to us a path that has two
walls running down the sides of this
path all the way down.
And in these two walls, there are doors
that are open, doorways you can walk
through all the way down.
And there are curtains hanging on each
of these doors concealing what is behind
them.
He says,
[Silence]
He says, "And at the entrance of this
path, there is someone there calling and
inviting everyone saying, "Oh people,
enter into the path of Allah.
together
and do not become distracted or go
crooked.
Go where the path takes you. Do not
deviate from this path.
He says
focus
[Silence]
He says, "And above this path, there's a
voice calling."
Every time someone who is in this path
gets curious about these open doors
and starts to wander and contemplate
moving the curtain over to see what's on
the other side,
this caller
calls from above and says, "Be careful.
Do not open that curtain. Don't look
behind it. Don't interfere with it. Keep
going straight
because if you open that curtain and
take a peek at what's behind, you're
going to walk through that door.
And immediately walking through that
door is what? Walking off of the path of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
So notice here how we have this big
broad inviting path. At the end of this
path
is Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Your journey to Allah.
And so as you're on this path
in this analogy that our prophet gives
us sallaihi wasallam every step you take
on this path
you're taking it whenever you implement
a sunnah of the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam.
In order to make
way or make any kind of distance down
this path, it is only by way of the
sunnah.
If you try to go down this path in your
own way or in a way that Muhammad Sam
did not take, you will not move an inch
forward. Not one inch.
No matter how much you run, you're
running in place until you are walking
the way that the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam did.
At the end of this path is your meeting
with Allah. Wherever your life ends,
that is where you will meet Allah. Some
people will meet Allah very far down the
path. And at the absolute furthest place
down that path is Muhammad sallall.aii
wasallam.
And right behind him are the remainder
of the prophets and messengers. Right
behind them are Abu Bakr and Omar and
Ali and the great companions of the
prophets and messengers
and so forth. Each person makes his
distance down this path based on how
closely he is following the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam.
You can't take a single step unless it
is exactly how our prophet took it. If
you try to walk down the path your own
way, you'll be moving a lot, but you'll
be treading water. Not one inch.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii alaihi
wasallam then breaks this analogy down.
He says saiam
continuing in the analogy.
[Silence]
Muslim.
He says sallall.aii wasallam the path
is Islam
and the two walls on either side of the
path those are the boundaries of Allah
and those open doors
they are the prohibitions of Allah. When
a person does something haram they walk
through one of those doors.
And innately if you walk through one of
those doors, you have walked off the
path.
He says, "And that caller that is above
the path that is with you as you walk
down that path, that every time someone
wants to peek behind one of those
curtains just to see what it's this
disobedience of Allah, I don't want to
go in. I just want to take a peek. I
just want to see what's going on on the
other side." You need to know, right?
you can't live in a bubble kind of
thing.
He says that is the conscience of the
Muslim.
The conscience of the Muslim. That
caller that every time you want to peek
behind one of those curtains, he says,
"Be careful.
Do not peek behind that curtain because
if you peek behind it, you're going to
enter that door." That is the conscience
of the Muslim in the heart of every
believer.
This is the path that we are asking of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala and this is
the journey that we are on. But it's
very important for us to realize
that the Quran
teaches us where the path is and how to
tread it.
But you cannot make a single inch
in distance. You can't move forward a
millimeter down that path unless you are
doing it in the same footsteps that the
prophet Muhammad took.
[Arabic recitation]